das große rätsel der sonne scheint
gelöst worden zu sein es ist nämlich
etwas verrückt je weiter man sich von
der sonne entfernt desto heißer wird es
von 5.500 kelvin bis zu 5,6 millionen
aber wie kann es heißer werden wenn man
sich von einer hitzequelle entfernt die
parkas solar sonne umkreist die sonne um
genau dieses geheimnis zu lüften sie ist
der schnellste flugkörper den menschen
je entwickelt haben jetzt sind die
ersten ergebnisse der mission publiziert
worden und sie sind spektakulär klicks
um science-fiction gibt es spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen seit dem sommer diesen jahres
2009 10 und kreis die nasa-sonde park
asola probt die sonne und soll dabei der
sonnenoberfläche so nahe kommen wie
bisher noch kein anderes menschen
gemachtes objekt vorher immer wieder
taucht sie ihn die korona ein und kommt
der sonne damit immer ein stückchen
näher
und das langfristig gesehen auf bis zu 9
sonnen radien mit dem begriff kroner ist
die äußerste schicht der sonne gemein
corona ist lateinisch und bedeutet so
etwas wie kranz oder krone die korona
bildet also wenn man so will die
atmosphäre den sonnenbrand der mehrere
millionen grad celsius heißer ist als
die oberfläche der sonne in der korona
können temperaturen von bis zu 5,6
millionen grad celsius herrschen bei
schlappen 5500 kelvin liegen die
temperaturen dagegen auf der
sonnenoberfläche doch warum ist das so
genau das ist eines der ganz großen
rätsel der sonne
die forschungsteams weltweit mit hilfe
der nasa-sonde lösen wollen warum ist
die äußere sonnen atmosphäre deutlich
heißer als ihrer oberfläche auch
bezüglich der sonnenwinde die auch den
strom und kommunikationsnetzen auf der
erde gefährlich werden könnten sind noch
viele rätsel offen wodurch wird dieser
strom von elektronen protonen und
anderen teilchen angetrieben denen die
corona in richtung der erde schießt wie
genau werden die sonnenwinde auf einen
wert im überschall bereich beschleunigt
dazu nicola fox eine der
wissenschaftlerinnen des nasa sonden
projekt der entstehungsort der
sonnenwinde die atmosphäre der sonne
ihre corona muss extrem energie
ein 300 mal so heiß wie die oberfläche
der sonne
das widerspricht den naturgesetzen es
sollte keine wärmequelle geben die
heißer wird wenn man sich von ihr weg
bewegt dort gibt es irgendeine
zusätzliche energie irgendeine schwarze
magie der solar- wind- löst sich nicht
einfach von der sonne nimmt irgendwie
auch ihr magnetfeld mit sich egal welche
richtung es zeigt wie stark es ist es
erstarrt im sonnenwind bisher weiß man
lediglich die bewohner besteht aus
extrem energiereichen gasen die von der
sonne verströmt werden von der erde aus
sehen wir sie nur bei einer totalen
sonnenfinsternis und zwar als
strahlenkranz um die sonne
internationalen forschungsteams haben
jetzt die ersten drei tauchgänge der
nasa sonde in die krone analysiert und
ihre spektakulären ergebnisse gleich in
vier studien der renommierten
fachzeitschrift nature veröffentlicht
jeweils offenbart sich ein ganz neues
bild von der sonne dass unsere
bisherigen vorstellungen von ihr
komplett auf den kopf stellt dazu der
nasa mitarbeiter thomas zurbuchen schon
diese ersten daten der partner sonne
zeigen unseren stern von einer ganz
neuen unerwarteten seite er bezieht sich
dabei auf die nasen umgebung die sich
als überraschend komplex und
strukturiert herausstellt auch der
sonnenwind in dieser region zeigt ein
völlig anderes verhalten als es die
fachwelt vermutet hat möglich werden
diese spektakulären erkenntnisse nicht
nur durch die tatsache dass die packer
sonne so nah an die sonne herankommen
die sonne umkreist die sonne mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 2000 kilometern pro
stunde
das entspricht in etwa der
geschwindigkeit mit der die sonne
rotiert und so kommt es dazu dass die
packers oder sonde über einen bestimmten
punkt der sonne schwebt zumindest für
einen gewissen zeitraum dieses manöver
ermöglicht es den fachleuten die
vorgänge in der korona und an der
sonnenoberfläche ohne die störenden
einflüsse der sonnen rotation zu
beobachten
so haben die forschenden jetzt messen
können dass änderungen im magnetfeld der
sonne dafür sorgen dass die sonnenwinde
beschleunigt werden bisherige missionen
konnten das rätsel nicht lüften warum
der sonnenwind schneller wird wenn er
die korona verlässt die nun
ausgezeichneten geschwindigkeiten
übertreffen übrigens noch mal alles was
forschungsteams im bisherigen
modellrechnungen angenommen hatten und
auch für das ganz große rätsel das große
mysterium gibt es nun einen
erklärungsansatz warum nämlich ist die
korona viel heißer
die oberfläche der sonne möglicherweise
liegt das an aufgespürten plasma wenn
dazu der us astronom justin caspar der
an der studie beteiligt war wenn man
sich der sonne näher zeigen sich plasma
wellen die vier mal so viel energie
haben wie die anderen
sie sind so stark dass sie die richtung
des magnetfeldes umkehren können und
genau das könnte zur aufheizung der
korona führen außerdem im fokus der
fachleute die sogenannten langsamen
sonnenwinde die sich mit
geschwindigkeiten von weniger als 500
kilometern pro sekunde fortbewegen die
aktuellen analysen legen nahe dass diese
ihren ursprung in den löchern der korona
haben die am äquator der sonne zu finden
sind außerdem selektierte die sonde
schafe scheren in den teilchen strömen
des sonnenwinds sogenannte switchback
registriert wurden diese als abrupte
umkehrung der magnetischen und
elektrischen felder die über die sonde
zogen und dann verschwanden die ursache
dieses ridgebacks ist bislang unbekannt
und muss noch erforscht werden
zusammengefasst ist es echt der reine
wahnsinn welche faszinierenden
erkenntnisse allein die ersten drei
tauchgänge der packers sommersonne
hervorgebracht haben eine absolute
sensation noch bis zum jahr 2025 soll
die mission fortgesetzt werden
an heiligabend in fünf jahren also am 24
dezember 2024 wird sie aber zunächst
noch den sonnennächsten punkt erreichen
dann wird sie sich der sonnenoberfläche
auf nur rund sechs millionen kilometer
distanz nähern und damit temperaturen
bis zu 1370 grad celsius trotz müssen
das ist mehr hitze und strahlung als ein
flugkörper je zuvor standhalten musste
ihr fast zwölf zentimeter dicke carbon
panzer wird das hoffentlich ermöglichen
dazu die nasa mitarbeiterin nikolov ochs
unser kleines raumschiff macht sich
unter brutalen bedingungen auf den weg
um überraschende und aufregende
enthüllungen nach hause zu schicken wir
können nur hoffen dass die packer soll
ab ob das aushalten wird dann werden die
ergebnisse sensationell werden aber
schon jetzt hat die forschung so viel
sensationelles über die sonne heraus
gefunden 100.000 grad künstliche sonne
auf der erde in betrieb genommen
jailbreaking lab anklicken anschauen und
breaking lab auf jeden fall abonnieren
kula kanal bis dann bleibt dran